and then I read a lot of books and
talked to a lot of a lot of smart people
you're self-taught yeah
think about your school experience you
memorize a whole bunch of statistics and
random facts and figures that help you
pass a test and then 99% of it vanishes
you can learn more from speaking to
people in 15 minutes
then if you spent your life doing
something rise and shine it's an spresso
time good morning believe nation it's
evan my one word is believe and i
believe in you i believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that i want to
see exploded onto the world so grab your
coffee and sip on today's message learn
it yourself over to you Elon Musk how
did you get the expertise to be the
chief technology officer of a rocket
ship company well I do have a physics
background that's helpful as a
foundation and then I read a lot of
books and talk to a lot of a lot of
smart people you're self-taught
yeah well it's self-taught yes meaning
um I didn't I don't have an aerospace
degree so how did you go about acquiring
the knowledge well I like said I had
read a lot of books talked to a lot of
people and and have a great team you'll
be surprised at how much you can learn
when you get rid of the idea that the
degree makes the difference
think about your school experience you
memorize a whole bunch of statistics and
random facts and figures that help you
pass a test and then 99% of it vanishes
where when you are learning something
that you know how to apply and is
directly applicable to your passion you
remember it and so that allows you to
learn really really really quickly you
either adopt a mindset where I love this
video
you are either Elon Musk or you are the
interviewer you are either Elon Musk and
you approach a situation you say I can
learn anything I will be self-taught I
will figure it out I will read books I
will watch videos I will teach myself
how to do this thing or you're like most
people that interviewer who will say
you're self-taught you didn't go to
school for this
and you need to decide right now what
camp you want to fall into as long as
you are in the yourself taught
questioning not possible mindset
limiting beliefs you're always gonna be
held back where if you can adopt the
mindset that I can learn anything that I
want to I can go up against experts
who've been doing this for years because
I just care more about this thing and
when I dedicate myself to something I
will learn it and be amazing at it if
that's your approach going in then guess
what who will be I look at my Instagram
account as an example it took me six
years to get to six thousand subscribers
or six thousand fans something like that
six years right there abouts and I just
never really put a priority on it in the
past month I've grown to by a thousand
plus so six years to get the six
thousand one month to get the seven
thousand and we're growing and we're
growing or growing and I haven't talked
about my Instagram account outside of
Instagram
apart from this now for those guys
watching I would love it if you want to
follow me on Instagram my first public
appeal so I've been studying I've been
spending extra time trying to understand
the algorithm
hashtag usage pictures quotes frequency
all of the things that make Instagram
important understanding stories
understanding highlights understanding
how to tag within stories and I'm
teaching people on my team how to do it
I had a call the other day with a
Instagram expert this is somebody who
gets paid to coach people on how to do
their Instagram accounts and when I'm
talking to him I'm talking the same
language I've only been doing this for a
week at that time but because I spent a
week immersing myself and understanding
what's happened on Instagram I can talk
at the same level as someone who's been
doing this for years and it's not to say
that I'm some amazing genius you could
do the same thing to you're just
preventing yourself from doing it
because you think you need to have years
of experience because you think you need
to have a degree because you think you
need to go to school for this whatever
the thing is that you want to learn if
you want to be great at it you can be in
a really really really short amount of
time if you just dedicate yourself to it
and so you need to decide do you want to
be that Elon Musk and believe that you
could teach yourself anything and be a
genius
at it or do you want to be the reporter
and always question everything and say
you're self-taught it's not possible
what mindset do you want to adopt now
I've got a special bonus clip for you
but before getting to the bonus clip my
question of the day is what was the last
thing that you taught yourself to do
that you are really proud of leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love enjoy the bonus clip and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event spresso
[Music]
learning is a lifelong thing it doesn't
end at Harvard Business School it's your
responsibility I think if you're in any
profession at all you have to do it
consistently all the time I think I
spend probably fifty or sixty percent of
my time learning reading talking to
people traveling that's the only way you
can keep on top of this global world of
ours and it's even tougher now because
of the globality of the businesses
you're all going to deal in how reading
is the most important one but the second
one which is often forgotten is talking
to other people you can learn more from
speaking to people in 15 minutes then if
you spent your life doing something they
can explain it to you and you can learn
from watching people you also are going
to learn by I'm gonna call it imitation
but by watching other very good people
and how they operate in difficult
circumstances I learned a lot of things
what not to do and a lot of what to do
by watching other people
I had one definition that I have for a
good team is a group of people that
makes better decisions as a whole then
it would individually make is a sum of
the parts and when you're I think most
smart people like learning right and I
mean that's like one of the thrills of
starting a company right is you're just
the learning curve can be so steep and
if you can set up a team dynamic where
you're constantly learning from the
people around you then I mean what's
better right these are the people I wake
up every morning and I want to I want to
go learn from and just from is that one
of your heuristics for hiring people to
to like hire people that you learn from
yeah and when building a team you want
it to you want to think about the
dynamic so that way you can maintain
this property that the team makes better
decisions as a group than any individual
would but like these charts only like
no sing good but we're gonna get you a
boat approaching you know I'd always be
like no I'll teach myself
I honestly personally I sucked at
singing it when I was like 17 like I was
awful horrible
I was the worst singer like this is all
a bad singers out there I was horrible
so you're right and every single day I
would listen to John Legend and I would
go on the back of the city bus cuz I was
very shy singing late and I couldn't
come in front of somebody in sing it's
very nerve-racking to sing yes what I
would do is I would go on the city bus
and go to the back back back
now it's similarly loved just when
people were there no matter what anyone
a diary that would sing really though
then I got a little bit started singing
a little high for me but I was just
thinking you would like you have a
pretty voice the muscles my vocals I
started getting stronger and I made on
me Father
you know singing is one of the most
important components to me so
that's how it all started the reason why
I'm versatile at singing is because I
taught myself and when I was teaching
myself I wanted to try to sound like
everything so I could teach myself how
to sing this way and sing this way you
know but never actually I think that
became you know the way I became versus
analyzing the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details